那么在这里面呢，就是那个刚才我们看到了一个什么东西呢？
你要想拿到结果的话呢，这里面就得办到一件事情。
刚才我们是说这个课题插过去的，所以这个工具，这个工具叫什么呢？
大家看一下，他总结了这么一件事儿。
你看啊，上面这个东西叫什么呢？
叫叫做做计划的工具，做计划的工具，做计划的工具。
它的缺点是什么呢？
它的缺点是就是
他都都都，他首先都没谈钱。
他都说他只是说你对IT有强烈的依赖，但是做EXCEL呢？
它的好处是什么呢？
简单灵活。
但是它的缺点是什么呢？
它的缺点很很明显，为啥你们不用EXCEL或者拉到这边来那个就是搞了呢？
所以你要想完成，你要想做这三件事儿，你必须要具备这种能力。
注意这个因果关系非常的强，就是如果说你搞懂过去发生什么，那你
只要去做个报表，如果你想知道现在是什么，做个仪表板。
如果你想知道未来是什么的话，你只能去做PLANNING。
所以问题来了，你怎么做PLANNING？
所以说白了，从这两天的这个课面向结果，它的一大核心就是做PLANNING。
而你在做PLANNING的时候，其实你你跳了什么叫跳了？
注意PLANNING是五年级应该学的东西，但是呢，你一年级、二年级、三年级、四年级的东西你还没有掌握，但是你就开始做五年级的了。
但是
五年级的这个问题很自然，因为老板会说了，我们现在是六月，到年底还有六个月的时间，但是我们距离目标实现，如果这么做下去，肯定是实现不了的，请问接下来六个月该怎么办？
这句话对于老板来讲是一个最自然不过的问题了，非常的合理，是不是？
老板很有资格应该问这个问题吗？
他一定不会说你这个报告分析了，我是六个月，前面六个月为什么怎么怎么着，为什么没做成没做成，注意从数据分析的角度，那是一个东西。
但是从管理学的角度，你只是帮老帮你的同事找了一堆理由。
我们公司为什么前六个月没有实现我们的目标？
你找了一个理由。
但是作为一个老板的话，作为CEO、作为执行者、作为职业经理人，他唯一想问你的问题是我们还有六个月，请问我该怎么做才能达成目标？
你能做到这件事儿吗？
好，如果你不能做到这件事儿，那一切的数据分析有什么意义呢？
那不是分析了个寂寞吗？
好了，那么现在这幅图放到这儿来了以后。
那么我们来看这个工具有没有用过，用过的同学可以那个举手示意。
这个工具有没有用过？
叫，注意啊，这个工具它有一个地方一定要注意，它的发音一定要发对，叫做 WOKU 一定要发 W W W，千万不要千万不要发发。
知道吧？
不要发发。
发的音要发窝的音，你万一发错了就不好了。
听懂了吧？
这个都没用过啦。
好了，既然你们有好多东西都没用过，所以你你们知道吗？
你们在咨询老师，我要咨询一下，我要上这个课，你都讲什么？
我跟你讲，我要跟你讲哇，Q，我要跟你讲那个，我要跟你讲那个，你说你你你你这就叫什么？
这就叫你在学习一个你。
根本不知道的东西，所以你你没有办法提出你要学习的需求。
所以我只能告诉你，你在学的是数据分析。
但是你们现在所说的学的数据分析已经跟很普通的数据分析已经完全不是在一个LEVEL了。
好了，那么在做这件事情的时候呢，为什么呢？
因为我们也在研究这件事情，因为我们经常也会受到很多的这个五百强企业的一些这个就是这个刁难也好，或者是很
正常的需求也好，因为人家也很关注的是呃，他最终的时间有限，那么他怎么去实现好他的这个东西。
好在这儿呢，呃，我还是简单的给大家就是介绍一下，如果你遇到了困难了，我们在什么地方呢，可以帮助到大家。
那这个是就是给大家介绍一下那个自己啦，就是本来是应该在开始的时候介绍，但是呢，那个开始的
时候还是先给大家一些铺垫，一些引这个引子。
好，就是这个就是关于我的介绍呢，我的定位呢，切入两个，就是第一个呢叫教练，第二个呢叫顾问。
教练是什么意思？
如果你想学正儿八经的数据分析的话，那么你这两天你体验到的就是跟别的地方的不一样的地方。
如果你所在的公司正在进行数字化转型的话，那么我们可以跟你一起来探。
探讨就是我这到了这个叫做所谓三十而立，四十不惑。
我都是工作了这么多年，我才我才搞清楚，就是我我我是来干嘛的？
就是我干的事儿，就是研究数据分析，或者准确讲是研研究怎么搞清楚什么是数据分析，怎么做好，并且让别人也会我我会的一切。
所以说。
我首先是个老师，同时还会数据分析，也就意味着你很有可能你旁边有一个高手，他虽然很会，但他教不会你。
还有一个人呢，他虽然很会教，但他教你东西基本上没用。
所以呢，要让这两个东西结合起来就不太一样了。
好，你们现在看到的是你们学习的最重要的第一个注意，这些东西都是自成闭环的，我只有我只讲四门东西，也不会再多了，也不会再少了。
为啥呢？
因为
第一个东西为什么最重要呢？
因为它直接面向商业结果。
就是如果让我在公司干一个活的话，如果我可以重新选的话，那我觉得我可能会比较偏向去搞跟这个管理会计有关的事儿。
我不会最，我不会去做数据分析。
为啥呢？
因为我要让它变成一个这样的感觉，就是不会不会弹琴的厨师不是一个好会计，能理解吗？
就是如果说，所以说我们要让自己的技能要去叠加，你本来是一
一个会计，但是呢你很会演讲，同时呢你英语又很好，而且呢你又把数据玩的非常的溜。
哇塞，你的这个本领太厉害了。
所以说所以说就是就是其其实就好像我能教的东西很多，我以前也教过什么 PPT 什么电子表格，我还教过演讲，我还教过怎么讲课，我还教过其他的东西，但是我发现那都不是那都不是我的都不是我的赛道，或者都都不是我的渠道。
所以呢，这个地方又给大家分享一个重要的事情。
你们公司有四个东西，你可能从来没搞清楚，或者你有没有注意？
但是马云这个像阿里巴巴经常说，这个公司一定有什么愿景、价值观、使命、企业文化，能听懂吗？
好了，那如果把这个事儿问到你似的身上，请问你的使命是什么？
如果你没搞清楚你的使命，那么你就不知道你要干嘛，所以你就会比较迷茫。
为啥？
因为你没搞懂你的使命。
所以这里面左洛老师跟大家分享的是我的使命，就是来教别人怎么去做数据分析。
我为啥是这个使命呢？
你们猜啊，因为赚钱呀，其实不是，其实不是，是因为你做这件事不枯燥。
当有困难的时候，你觉得由于他的不枯燥，他能够平衡那个困难。
至于他赚没赚钱，那个是属于边际效应。
所以呢，你一定要找到一个当然了。
所以说大家你要这么想，所以因为有很多同学他也问这样的一个事情，说那个我我做数据分析，那么你一定要想我做会计或者我做IT或者什么，他是不是你在遇到困难的时候你会感觉到不枯燥，那你就可以去平衡那个困难。
好，那么在这儿呢可以看到呢，这些都是我们服务过的一些品牌。
那那么
这个呢，就是这个以前其实其实我有很多的工作还没有还没有做。
比如说像这些公司的这个伙伴都来学过课，所以你真别以为啊，就是很多人就是真的。
已经学了很多的东西了，我我我我这里面其实还没统计，就是好多的东西是其实我的私信有有有的人他突然跟我说，他说左老师你帮了我很多，我也不知道帮了他啥，他突然递了一个他的什么。
了一个新的offer，年薪在一百万以上。
我操，这个太恐怖了。
就是他不是因为我教了他的东西，让他年薪一百万，他一定是刚才我说的这种叠加效应。
就是很可能他本来是个管理者，本来是个CFO，但是呢他去了一个新的大的公司，那他可能别人需要的就是别的CFO没有的那个本事。
所以呢，就是这这个呢，你你要把这个我们讲的东西拿走，变成你的这个技能之一。
好，这个。
这个是大家可以看到，这是用power BI可以做出来的东西。
但这并不是我们这两天讲的重点，因为这里面的东西呢，它既有结果，也有过程，也有很多的东西。
所以我们要做的是摘出我们最精华的一些一些东西给到大家。
所以这个是什么？
汽车行业呀，奢侈品行业呀，这个制造行业呀，医疗行业呀，然后这个零零零售行业，医疗器械行业，还有什么医药行业，当然做这些。
东西都会很花时间的物流行业。
好，所以说如果说你公司是某种板块的话，那个想聊一些公司遇到的问题。
所以今天我们也是请了两个企业的实施顾问，他们做了很多的项目，就是刚才 Nancy 老师介绍的，在后面的 Jim 老师和 Jeffrey 老师，大家课间和中午如果要交流的话，你们吃完饭可以早点回来，跟后面的两个老师聊一聊，哎，我们公司遇到什么问题，我们公司遇到什么问题，我可以怎么怎么做，我可以怎么怎么做。
说好，所以说我说的这个第一个事儿，你一定要记住，在数据方面你有问题的时候，你一定要找老师，就是老师肯定能帮到你。
注意啊，老师之间的不同，你知道在于哪里吧？
老师之间的不同，你一定要明白一个关键的问题。
有的老师他永远讲课，但他自己实际上是没做过事儿的。
能能能能理解吧？
我们是在一线打仗的，咱们是在一线打仗的。
所以说一线发生什么，我们要最先知道，而很有可。
可能就是就是一线的东西，它已经是要与时俱进的。
好，那在这里面呢，我们来这个回到我先花点时间把这个我们的PPT做完啊，这个过过一下，我们不就进入到这个呃，就进入到操作的环节了，因为操作有很多好，我们再来看一下。
嗯，数据分析能力的成熟度这个其实之前我说过很多次了，就是叫做描述性分析、诊断性分析、预测性分析、规范性分析。
什么意思？
就是发生了什么、为什么发生、将会发生什么、如何让它发生。
老板真正重视的其实是最后一个境界，叫做如何让它发生。
如何让它发生就是
如何让我年底的时候能实现我的目标？
所以这个就是叫做PLANNING的这个比PLANNING还要更高一阶的境界。
就是你不只要做一次PLANNING，你要做好几个PLANNING，要去对比它们之间谁好谁坏，最终能够让它去实现。
好，我们为了让这件事情变得更加的可行，大家请看你所提的问题可能会在这里边的任何一个阶段，我们在这中间加了一个东西叫做标准化分析。
为什么？
因为刚才
刚才我们放那个很酷炫的东西的时候，就比如说我们在诊断性分析的这里面有一个很酷炫的、做的很酷炫的POWER BI这种东西要做好看，需要天赋。
但是我们做数据分析的时候，其实主要是要这个思路，所以我们希望它能够做的标准。
那这样的话呢，我们就把刚才的四个阶段呢变成了五个阶段，变成了五个阶段叫做五层模型。
那么在这个五层的模型里面呢，大家这个就可以看明白这个事情就是商业智能和
预算与计划，它正好在这里面是一个什么样的一个分布呢？
大家可以看右边的这幅图，在描述性分析和诊断性分析这个地方都是属于BI的范畴。
但是如果说你想要去做预测性分析和规范性分析，那么你就来到了高级分析的范畴，而这部分范畴你就需要去用PLANNING。
那么有的同学有你在网上如果去搜预测性分析，它很可能
告诉你的是这样的答案，他会说你可以用人工智能，你可以用机器学习，然后去预测一下，去跑个什么数据挖掘，去预测一下或者是什么什么东西。
好，这件事儿呢，它有两个问题。
第一个问题是这件事儿跟你没啥关系，因为机器在跑嘛。
第二件事儿呢，就是很有可能这个东西的成本很高，或者是它的算法或者怎么样。
所以说白了，这个就是它不能代替的人的一个一个东西，就是人会有很多的知识，而人做预测是什么预测呢？
是拍。
脑的预测，但是你如何让你拍脑的拍得更准呢？
那就是考察你的PLANNING的那个能够做的快准狠的能力了。
所以说说白了，就是如果你PLANNING足够的快准狠，相当于你是一台万能机器学习。
所以说可以我们去用机器去做预测性分析或者怎样，但是这两个条件就是第一个它可能很贵，第二个它可能很复杂。
当然了，还可能有一个东西就是嗯，可能这个公司。
根本驾驭不了这件事儿，但是更通用的是用人通过PLANNING的方式去做。
而且这个人可以PLANNING好几次，也就是所谓的ROLLING FORECAST。
而且你可以做好几个版本。
好了，那这里面如果我们总结一下的话，我们就会发现这个东西跟我们平时所问的问题有什么相关性呢？
我们总结了一个模型叫做五层六项模型，看到了吗？
这也是一个框架。
所以我们这一次讲学跟其他的一个讲学最大的不同在于，在其他的课程当中，你所学到的所有东西都是知识。
点，但是我们在这儿呢，一上来只告诉大家两个东西，一个叫底层逻辑，另外一个呢就是只讲框架。
框架就是就是它永远不变。
我现在画的这个框架，它就永远不变。
好了，我们这个框架呢分成了左边和右边。
左边你可以大家大家可以看一下它显示的是什么？
面向数据、面向历史、面向现在、面向未来。
这一张这张页面，这张图其实是真的。
是让大家可以足以反思很多事情。
如果你如果你想反思自己做的事，到底是到底是在干嘛？
有的同学说，哎呀，我干了这么多年，我干了个寂寞，那是为啥呢？
因为你到底在面向什么干活？
你到底是在面向数据干活，还是面向历史干活，还是面向现在干活，还是面向未来干活？
所以大家要自己想一想，你觉得面向什么干活最有意义啊？
如果你回答
大家面向未来干活最有意义，但是你很可能在上课的之前你提出的需求是：老师，我有一堆文件怎么合并起来？
这件事属于面向什么？
面向数据能听懂吗？
所以说我们知道我要去把一堆文件合起来，但是你同时还要知道你做这件事它的本质是在面向数据。
所以说那么问题来了，在你们公司有没有人在做面向未来的事儿？
那么为什么面向数据这个事儿被你做了呢？
为啥你没有机会去做面向未来的事儿呢？
就首先你得认识到有这么一个划分好了。
如果你从右边看的话，你就会发现数据处理报表、仪表板、可视化仪表板和计划预算。
所以你会发现，就是就是做计划和预算，它是引领着所有的东西在跑的。
所以说很有可能你既不会做计划，也也做不出来你要的那种想要的预算可视化仪表板。
也做不出来报表，你也做不出来报表，仪表板也做不出来数据处理，也没处理好好了。
注意它是位于不同位置的，那么这里面我们要解决的事情，你看有这么多数据源，如何把它整合在一起？
第一层就叫描述性分析，你看在在这里面是这样子的。
第二层叫诊断性分析，我们把这两个又分成了两个格，分别叫第三层标准化分析和定制化分析。
什么意思？
注意这是特意在我们
经常问问题的区间类给人去做做一个划分，为啥呢？
因为左边写的第三层标准化分析，我告诉你这个你能学得会；
右边的叫第三层定制化分析，我告诉你这个你学不会。
你知道什么意思吧？
最近有一个前两天有个案例非常火，叫做中国有一个女生中专参加了阿里巴巴举办的什么全球数学竞赛，第一名什么叫做北京大学，第二名清华大。
大学第三名，什么叫叫叫什么什么什么什么哈佛大学第四名，什么大学第十二名，中国江苏什么什么什么什么什么中专中等技术学校，他觉得怎么不这么不和谐。
你你们知道为什么他能被挤在中间出现这么一号人吗？
这是天赋使然，能理解吧？
所以告诉大家，天赋这种东西是没有办法学的。
你要上我这门课，你现在应该。
记记录两个三个关键的节点了，就是你做所有的事情。
如果你不面向结果去做的话，过程会耽误你非常非常多的时间。
人只有一个东西是平等的，就是时间。
第二件事儿，第二件事儿就是你得找到你的使命，越早越好。
你的使命的意思就是你要干嘛？
那你未来就不会浪费时间。
第三件事儿就是你有没有发现你的天赋。
我告诉你，那个中学的那个学生，那个中专的这个案例，你没有仔你你看那些就是互联网上抖音那个说法是不好的。
为啥呢？
因为因为那个同学你看他那个卷子，他有的数学考试是考了八十多分的。
如果说他不参加这个比赛的话，他正常干嘛是发不现这个混事儿的，可能最多就是说哎，他有一个爱好是学数学，但是他不知道他自己都不知道的理解吧。
所以你知道吗？
做右边的这个。
这个可视化仪表板的这个这个同学就有天赋，为啥呢？
因为我跟他沟通完了以后，发现他原来是学英语专业的，并且呢去了什么这个律师律师事务所去统计一些统计一些案件或者是干嘛的。
但是他在做可视化设计的时候，他连传给我的P P T，我都觉得那东西就是被他当成了一个美工的东西在用，他是具有天赋的。
再加上他对数他后来又转行了数据分析。
所以他其实按照他的天赋在转行的。
那么我告诉大家，就是右边这个东西是学不会的。
我们有人一直在研究，哎，复刻他、抄袭他、模仿他。
后来我们抄袭和模仿的同学发现一件事儿，他说还是就他这个颜色好看，你怎么改了以后就是不好看？
你不知道你们有没有发现这件事儿，就是那个东西一旦弄出来了以后，你这个颜色只要一调，反正别人就觉得很丑，你就不调，就是对的。
哎，这东西就没办法，就是你说这东西。
所以大家一定要明白，所以我为什么放个第三层，就是我要给你讲你能学会的，还要提示你有一些东西你是学不会的。
好，所以说我们讲课的路线，如果我们这两天注意这两天是爬山，这爬山的路线是从左边走，注意啊，从左边上山，右边上山比较危险，你要自己感兴趣，你从右边上挑战自己的天赋，尤其是问老师，老师我这个做的比较丑，你看你怎么教我让我做的漂亮，老师自己认为自己也做的比较也。
比较丑，但是我只是知道这个里面的逻辑。
所以我们从左边上山，这就是这种我们要攀登的山峰，明白吧？
你的老板提的问题需要你爬到顶峰，所以如果你不知道这座山峰的存在的话，你很很可能不太容易回答这个问题。
好了，那么为了解决这件事情的话呢，那么老师的确是这个是解决了这个问题的，叫做道法术器四个层面，就是就是但是呢，建议大家一进来。
的时候呢，就把这个法玩好就行了。
那那么什么意思呢？
法是面向结果的，道是面向什么的？
面向框架。
而我说的这个术是面向什么呢？
面向过程。
所以说你说，哎，老师我要做那个波士顿矩阵，老师我要做那个做那个新老客户，哎，老师我要做那个什么什么帕雷托分析，哎，老师我要做那个人群分析，你知道这些都是什么人群分析，分析完了有结果吗？
所以这些所有的问题提问的都是在过程层面。
所以这件事大家先要分清楚，好。
所以说这叫面向过程的数据分析。
那还有同学唉，老师这个按钮在哪儿怎么找不到？
这叫面向工具，知道吧？
但是如果你把上面这三件事全学懂，你这个工具就能发挥它的最大极致。
能听明白吗？
好，假设你这个地方是什么概念呢？
假设你买了一辆车，假设你买了辆车，你那个车的表底显示。
它可以开到三百公里，能听懂吧？
请问你有没有把车开开到过它的表底的那个数字？
那是为什么呢？
是因为主要是因为你不会开车，你明白吧？
所以说如果前面这三件事你会了，你很有可能能把这个工具开到三百公里的时速，那是很恐怖的。
所以你一上来千万不要指望把这个东西学得很怎么怎么样。
所以这里面有POWER BI的书籍，有一本叫DS权威指南。
有没有看过？
看过的同学可以举个手。
嗯，这本书有一千页，你挺会找的。
就是你基本上看了一本修车指南，就是那个你看到第这个八百多页的时候，你基本上已经知道那个车怎么修了。
但是呢，很有可能有出现这种问题，就是很多的人他会修车，但他其实并不知道从北京到上海怎么走。
这是这句话在形容什么呢？
就是很有很多的程序员，他能把车开的很快，但他并不知道在这个公司要要。
干嘛能能听懂吗？
所以说这里面你要选择到底是会导航还是会开车，还是会修车。
你说老师我全都要，这也是可以的。
好，那么我们的入口是从法的层面介入，所以叫做业财分析之道。
好了，在这里面要告诉大家呢，讲一个事呢，叫做职事业发展。
什么概念呢？
就是就是那个。
别人做我也做，我更努力。
这就是你，就是你靠什么赚钱？
叫做体力差。
别人做我也做，但是你会的更多。
这叫知识差别。
知道了别人不知道的，这就是信息差。
所有人都以为地球是平的，但是你知道那是圆的。
这就是认知差。
好，我们这门课基本上是在就是就是叫做第一和第二个层面，就至少是在信息差往上。
的，所以你说哎，老师，那我这个不会点的，我这小白的那个知识怎么补？
注意知识已经给你准备了辅助的视频课程了，不是推荐你要预习，你要跟他这个吗？
这就是为什么这两天的主课的原因，大家就能搞明白了。
因为主课里面给你讲体力怎么玩，给你讲认知识怎么怎么怎么弄，你不合算。
主课你最重要的就是你不要跑偏，所以认知哦。
老师，我我搞明白了，原来地球是圆的，我这个太恐怖了。
因为这个东西能帮助你彻底知道地球到底咋回事儿。
好了，所以呢，这个在我的刚才的我的几个大的这个课里面，就是每个课讲知识也发展给出的东西是不一样的。
在这个课里面，就是告诉大家你的价值。
刚才不是有个同学说价值这个问题吗？
老师，这个用价值去换结果。
那我你你你仔细想一想，在公司是这个事。
是，就是每天做报表的，每天出数的。
你说他是在工作在哪个层面？
每天做报表的在出数的，他工作在哪个层面？
他是不是工作在体力层面啊？
能明白吗？
是不是如果说他招一个，哎呀，我们这个缺了一个什么什么人，他招了一个会这个知识的人，这叫工作在什么层面？
工作在知识层面对不对？
信息是不一样的，信息是可能会告诉。
诉你信息就是就是告诉你 AI 来了，但是呢你不知道这个信息能干嘛，认知是什么？
认知是告诉你 AI 和数字能几乎代替90%的人的工作。
而这个认知，哦，我知道了地球是圆的，那你不知道能干嘛，这个很恐怖，所以所以呢，你可以不知道，但是你要知道，人们创造价值的级别是不一。
一样的，所以说你你的所有的问题集中在什么什么位置。
你有说老师这个东西怎么让它那个自动合并，怎么什么？
如果说你每天所有的问题都在问第三层和第四层的，那么你就生活在这样的一个价值带。
你的收入不是被公司锁定，不是被社会锁定，是被你自己锁定在这个位置。
那么你想要去改变的话，你你自己可以。
我我我虽然不能告诉你怎么改变，但是我
我给你了一个衡量方法，你自己可以对照你发现你每次在思考的东西是在哪一个价值层面。
那么你交付的结果一定是那个价值层面也能换回的啊。
很简单，如果老板认为再招一个人，你会的他都会，那么你就工作在知识层面。
如果老板认为哎呀，再招一个人他不一定会了，那你至少是在信息层面了。
如果这个人他携带着资源，而且他能判断未来的走向，那这个人他什么事都不用干。
只需要指出方向就够了。
马云他的那个有一次这个大会上，他的十八个人之中有一个人说了，他说了，他说我我最敬仰马总的是什么？
就是我们十八个人都不知道他在说啥。
但是呢，他还拿了一个钥匙告诉我们说，这是五年以后你们在欧洲的一个庄园的别墅的旁边的车库的宝马的七的这个钥匙，他们每个人都在笑。
但是呢，他们就这么无端端的信了。
那么这就是马云就是公。
工作在这个层面好了，那么我们做数据分析其实也是一样的，也存在这样的一个结构。
所以这个东西要让大家知道有这么一个结构。
好了，先回答一个非常关键的问题，叫做这个问题又要考大家了。
我们很多的同学有可能是在做业务，有可能是在做财务，又有可能是在做什么财务B P，有可能是在做业务B P H R B P，还有或者是在做什么。
但是呢，你可能面临的一个问题就是商业的业。
业务是什么呢？
业务是商业的过程，它是指标驱动，财务是什么呢？
商业的结果，科目驱动。
好了，就是这两个东西呢，它不通，它不打通，或者就中间这个问号，就是怎么让？
就是这里面，这里面如果让你填个字，你应该填什么字？
就是先在这里面画了一个问号，就是这是财务，这个是业务，但中间画了一个问号，这个问号就是一个空格，让你填一个字，你填的这个字是什么？
好，线上的同学也可以填这个字。
哎，让如果让你填这个字，你填的是什么？
数据都有啊，但但它并不解决问题啊。
财务有财务数据，业务有业务数据，但是你有了又能如何呢？
你有的数据只能给你带来问题，只能给你带来麻烦。
所以中间这个字很肯很肯很显然，中间这个字是一个很关键的字，它绝对不是帮你带来麻烦的，它是能。
能够帮你解决问题的，那么这个字填应该填什么？
填什么？
IT IT给你带来更大的麻烦，你要去装。
哎，我老师，我要装一下你的EXCEL BI PRO，IT说不安全，不能装，我要用POWER BI，不能装，我要用它，不能装，都不能装。
IT不能给你解决问题，它只能给你制造麻烦，是不是吗？
和和他和他怎么？
怎么样呢？
他和他怎么样呢？
和问题是好，这个和其实他提出的是个问题，怎么合起来呢？
好，我告诉大家，这个字又是现在你应该记在纸上的字了，你把这个字记了以后，这个字是我们上午最重要的一个字。
你看我上午讲的都是我上午讲的都是底层原理，这个字如果你记住了以后，我告我告诉你，以后遇到任何不
问题了，不知道该怎么办，立马看这个字。
这个字是你一切问题的终极解决方案，就一个字，你要出了问题，这就就是因为这个字前面加了个不，你要没有那个问题，就是这个不去掉了。
不解。
好，注意这个字就是，哎，你有没有发现，就是当年发水发大水了以后，发大水了以后，大禹治水。
水这个故事听过吧？
大禹治水这个故事主要解决的是一个什么问题呢？
大禹治水之前，有的人是怎么治水的呢？
你你想一想，你们公司是不是也是一样的呢？
需要有一个人来治一下，所以这个字非常核心的这个字就叫，就一个字就叫通。
你你今天如果不舒服，为啥呢？
因为你哪不通，所以你不舒服。
你为啥跟他吵架了呢？
不通，为啥跟老板不通？
沟通，所以你你会发现，在在说话里面有个词叫沟通，你没有沟他就不通，有了沟他就通。
所以如果这里面做一个扩展的提问，大家可以回去自己想交流和沟通这两个词有什么区别，你们有没有想过？
哎，这个这个我们在这不讨论了啊，就是，但是这个
字你知道吗？
你这个字放在通在数据里面是什么概念？
就是你看啊，你的你的数据EXCEL一堆，什么东西一堆。
你之所以为什么做不出来，我告诉你就一个字，是因为你的数据不通。
而且所有的数据的产品要想做好的话，它只有一个字，就是彻底打通。
所以从某种角度来讲，我们应该有一种体验，就是我们点一下我的这个报告，我只要点一下刷新，我的工作应该怎么样呢？
一切结束。
一切结束，只有底层只有一个字，就是因为它全通了，所以才能一下结束。
能明白吗？
好了，如果说到这个问题的话，我现在就问你这么一件事儿：EXCEL是一个东西，POWER BI是一个东西，请问EXCEL的水能不能流到POWER BI里面去？
那肯定能嘛，不然你怎么用POWER BI嘛？
问题反过来问：POWER BI的水能不能再流回EXCEL，怎么流？
哎，power BI的水怎么流回excel？
你不要说老师，我导出excel，你导出excel中间不是给power BI和excel接了个管子，是你每次一盆一盆的往外往外泼，你懂吗？
你要power query能从excel接管子接到power BI上吗？
注意要通这个字，它的最形象的想象就是要接根管子。
你之所以excel的
水能灌到 power BI 里面去，是因为在 power BI 上面点了一下刷新，这个水呜灌进来了，点一下刷新，呜灌进来了，有没有这么一种体验？
在电子表格上面点一下刷新，power BI 里的水呜灌过来了，有没有？
怎么弄？
这个就是，这就是为什么我们给大家了，给大家了这个工具，所以你们有没有，你们你有，你们有没有这个装这个工具，叫做 Excel BI Pro 好了。
好了，这个工具解决的一个核心的事情就是通。
但是这个通这个字，请你要明白，它不是只是在这里面适用，它是一个第一性原理。
我们遇到的所有的问题的底层逻辑都是因为它不通。
你要想解决它的方法，一定是顺着怎么让它通去解决。
因为POWER BI和EXCEL不通，那么我们解决的我们用的方法就用它来解决好了。
这个工具如果你打开的话，你会发现在这里面有一个有一个东西叫我们现在就可以。
体验一把，这里面有个东西是不是叫连接指标平台，看到了吧？
如果我点这个连接指标平台的话，它会告诉我说你可以连接这个 power BI 的文件，注意这个 power BI 文件在哪呢？
注意，你是不是也能点？
你如果现在操作的话，你也能点。
你说你连的 power BI 文件在哪？
你不知道在哪，对吧？
我告诉你，它在云端。
你点了这个。
你点了这个确定了以后，现在是不是出来了一堆东西？
好，请你做一个操作，把产品子类别放在行，再把这个里面的指标库里面的叫做销售指标的订单的这个订单销售额放在值，这个透视表就做出来了。
但是你根本找不到 power 边在哪，但是 power 边就像一个水池子一样，它的水被连了过来，所以你们下午将会学习这个工具怎么连 power 边，也就意味着你既学。
你会既学习怎么把 Excel 做到 power BI 里，你还会学习 Excel 再怎么连 power BI。
注意这两个水能循环起来，就是水循环。
所以那个这个我们休息一下，休息十分钟，十一点那个二十，那个大家可以自己先自行体验体验这东西。
我们这个东西以后，这个东西用过的同学举手一下。
用过这个东西的很少。
好，那么大家自己去自行先自行体验。
我们休息十分钟，十一点那个二十回来，我们就开始来操作了。
所以呢，你在体验这个东西的时候，你才真正发现这个跟透视表有很多的区别。
好，那正好遇到什么问题的，可以问一问旁边的老师。
嗯，大家好，我们那个如果要上洗手间的话，这个。
出门，然后往这边拐，就过去可以看到。